we begin now in kiev where we've been
following the developments of un
secretary general antonio gutierrez uh
he has just left butcher which was the
scene of some alleged atrocities by
russia u.n secretary general antonio
guterres is visiting ukraine after being
in moscow last hour he was in borodyanka
near the capital where he was speaking
to residents amongst heavy security and
it appears there is still very much a
high security presence around the un
secretary it's believed he'll now head
on to urpin and we have been following
his movements throughout his time in
ukraine russian forces allegedly
committed a litany of apparent war
crimes in this area of butcher during
their occupation of the town which is
about 30 kilometers northwest of the
capital guterres has called for moscow
and kiev to work together to set up aid
and evacuation corridors it's been more
than two months since russia's invasion
of ukraine and it appears that the un
secretary general is now heading off to
his next location for more on his visit
to ukraine let's bring in hada abdel
hamid who joins us from butcher on the
phone hello there hamid what's um
expected to happen at his next location
well we're actually in the convoy
heading to europe
that's another
town that has been
uh badly hit while the russian
during the russian occupation there and
you probably remember
uh those very dramatic pictures of
civilians fleeing under the shelling
from under
a bridge that had been uh bombed out now
it's a very busy schedule for the
secretary uh general um
he stopped here in borudjank and bucha
were very brief
uh he saw the devastation for himself he
still still
burnt out apartment blocks he saw the
uh houses flattened to the ground and in
bhutan he went to the site where the
mass grave was found now in borodyanka
he did say that war in the 21st century
was an absurdity and then he went on on
a personal note saying that he could
imagine his granddaughters living
in one of those apartment blocks that
were completely charred and reduced to a
carcass and imagining his granddaughters
fleeing uh in a panic for safety under
the shelling so that was a very personal
note from the secretary general but the
tough conversations are gonna happen
when he returns to keefe where he's
gonna meet first with the uh foreign
minister the michigan and then with
president zielinski himself and top of
the agenda is those humanitarian
corridors that the secretary general has
been calling for in coordination with
the international red cross
hoda stay with us we want to hear more
of your thoughts on his visit but we're
just going to get the latest from the un
secretary he spoke a short time ago in
butcher
when we see this
horrendous site
it
makes me feel
important it is
a thorough investigation
and
accountability i am glad that supreme
court he sees this situation that the
prosecutor's office was already here
i fully support the international
criminal court and i appeal to the
russian federation to accept to
cooperate international criminal courts
but when
we talk
war crimes
we cannot forget
that
what
of crimes
is war
itself
thank you very much
okay let's bring back hoda abdel hamid
who is following guterre's visit
uh hoda this conflict has certainly
tested the limits of un diplomacy
how much of a challenge has this been
to or for the
well secretary-general he has come under
a lot of criticism uh you know we are
two day a month into the war uh and he's
just coming now to see for himself what
has happened and that is at the back of
several high level visits uh over the
past few weeks ever since these areas
where uh street now
ukraine has expressed some uh
disappointments and frustration uh with
what is so like a lack of action from uh
the u.n if you remember at some point uh
president valencia was asking for russia
to be expelled from the security council
which is something that is very
difficult for the
secretary general uh to make happen uh
but so and he cannot at this point also
offer anything when it comes to
mechanisms
to end the conflict to bring about a
ceasefire that is not on the table
anytime soon so what he can do at this
stage is uh as we heard him there talk
about war crimes call for an
investigation and the u.n did release a
statement ahead of his visit
saying that there was growing evidence
of
um
of uh war crimes that happened not only
in this area that he's gonna he's
visiting this morning but also in other
places around the country like our team
and we still don't have the full picture
of what happened in mariupol
so he's going to concentrate on the
humanitarian track try to bring about
now these
corridors state passages
for people uh especially those that are
still uh locked into that as of south
key plant in mariupol with it's uh
there's supposed to be around a thousand
civilians there uh i think the biggest
uh challenge will be and to make sure
that uh among them you don't have some
of the soldiers
that are also hooked up in that plant
that sneak out take off the military
uniform and then tries to get out among
the civilians that is something that
russia would not accept
under any condition
so certainly yes the talk of
humanitarian corridors also in other
places around the country in the south
and
the east now as the russians are making
this slow advance in the donbass region
all of that the secretary general can
try to help and try to bring about
but it's certainly a very difficult
challenge because of the level of
mistrust
between ukraine and russia all right
thank you very much for bringing us up
to speed hoda abdul hamid live for us
following guterre's visit to ukraine and
we'll cross back you uh he's expected to
be in urpin next thank you hodder